couronne de fleurs maquillage
psychédélique ou encore guitare
acoustique à Versailles le parfum de
l'été se mêle avec une ambiance hippie
une recette qui a du succès auprès des
petits et des grands pensant qu'il y a
une bonne ambiance et il y a beaucoup
d'enfants donc ça c'est chouette aussi
voilà ouais c'est sympa c'est une
ambiance un peu épine non
les visiteurs ont pu s'essayer à des
activités sportives se restaurer et
admirer les performances artistiques de
créateurs yvelinois comme ce peintre qui
a réalisé une toile autour de la
création florale des bons retours les
gens sont assez content de voir une
oeuvre secrète devant eux et voilà il me
pose des questions par rapport à ce que
j'ai un modèle voilà est-ce que ça vient
de moi voilà sa coiffure évoque une rose
une fleur voilà
la nature les plantes le vivant voilà
entièrement gratuites la gardienne
partie se veut accessible à tous chaque
année l'événement prend de l'ampleur et
attire au-delà des frontières
yvelinoises notamment les parisiens et
des habitants des Hauts-de-Seine
de plus que l'année dernière donc
effectivement on est un peu victime de
notre succès mais c'est dans la même
lignée de notre événement de Noël qu'on
organise donc on est sur 10000 personnes
à la journée
victime de son succès une prochaine
édition et d'ores et déjà prévu pour
l'année prochaine